what's cooking my name is Chef Elisa
Reynolds executive chef and host of
searching for soul food I'm here with
Adriana adame and Alex Hill AKA a cozy
kitchen and just add hot sauce they're
gonna take me through some soul food
recipes that are near and dear to their
heart tell me a little bit more about
your delicious recipe today we are
making tayarines Verdes which is my
childhood favorite my mom used to make
this for me whenever it was like a
weeknight and this is sort of like a
fast meal it's Peruvian so this is kind
of like a hybrid Italian Peruvian combo
because it uses some Latin ingredients
and then obviously Italian ingredients
it's kind of like Grazie gracias exactly
yes for this recipe we are going to use
evaporated milk olive oil neutral oil
shallot garlic pine nuts some salt and
pepper queso fresco spinach basil and
spaghetti okay Alex yeah tell me about
your recipe okay so this is a famous
Puerto Rican snack tostones and we have
the Mojo garlic sauce what you don't
really want to kiss anyone after because
you're going to be like very garlicky
but it's so good it's so good it's so
good so we have some vegetable oil that
we are frying the toston as in garlic
yes white vinegar some extra virgin
olive oil some adobo we have pepper some
salt
and we have some green plantains not
ripe plantains green plantains let's get
it going also I have my grandfather's
pillow you didn't bring that that's so
great I was in Peru searching for soul
food I'm here with you and I would love
you to just take me on the journey
through this recipe it's super simple
it's like a it's a pesto essentially
like a Latin pesto so we're gonna start
with just dropping some pasta in our
salted water love this and then I
toasted up some pine nuts okay and I'm
gonna add all of the ingredients to a
blender and we're just gonna mix it up
bring the soul out of the dish it's just
such a mix of different cultures coming
together throughout the history of Peru
the history is very like mixed the
Africans way at the beginning
is like yeah so it's like look at me I'm
like
our honorary Peruvian over here hell
yeah how far back can you think about
when you discovered this recipe or when
your parents like threw it on you this
has been in my family forever in every
Puerto Rican culture in the Dominican
culture this is like a snacking dish so
we're gonna first do the first fry and
you just want to get like golden brown
and then you do it again is it a morning
dish is it afternoon can you eat it all
the time I mean I eat all the time but
it's usually like a lunch and a dinner
recipe okay and you just dip it and it's
like it's so good I'm here for it yeah
I'm here for it now what's happening
over here we got the pasta so we cook
the pasta not overcooked yeah we have a
little pasta water on the side because
that's going to kind of help with our
sauce with the right consistency so I'm
just going to blend this up
I love the color already
turns like a really bright green
spaghetti
come on what does soul food mean to you
I feel like soul food for me is all
about food that just feels good okay
yeah for me it's Korean love Yeah like
that's really what soul food means to me
every time anyone talks about Soul Food
the word Love Is Always Somewhere yes
well for me I'm black and Puerto Rican
and like I was raised heavily on both
cultures wow so I'm giving you soul food
and I'm getting Puerto Rican food you
know and my parents made sure that I was
raised like that yes well I'm excited to
try both of your cultures and your
family yes history in these meals so I
have a question okay so what was your
favorite place to travel in the series
and
your favorite food
[Music]
yeah yeah Peru really really did it for
me and you know what it wasn't
necessarily A
dish it was a drink what was the drink
the purple corn drink
Pisco Sour right exactly that was just
delicious and what I loved about it it
was something that the entire country
wrapped their arms around man this looks
so good guys that's my dance not this
not this not this oh
Mr cameraman no kisses for you
the cake I'm so happy that
tradition follows us wherever we go and
sometimes we can turn it into a business
yeah
[Music]
yes
this is going to be
amazing my favorite line these days is
history on a plate
oh I like that we can try it
are we eating cheers guys cheers
Club
um
[Music]
thanks for watching and make sure you
check out searching for soul food now
streaming on Hulu also send me your
favorite recipes with the hashtag soul
food Hulu period period and be sure to
follow me just that hot sauce you can
find me at a cozy kitchen on all social
platforms
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]